[Musique]
TPMP s'est rendu à la fête de la musique
et on est tombé sur un phénomène un bobo
texan moi je suis en mode country
aujourd'hui je vous préviens alors si
vous voulez du burger
on a tous ce qu'il vous faut ici après
si vous fait autre chose vous me
proposez c'est à vous de proposer et si
vous pensez que Guillaume Genton était
un mytho et ben on a trouvé son maître
c'est qui ton chroniqueur préféré
ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas regardé
je vais pas te mentir dis-moi au pif euh
François civil je sais pas je connais
pas il est tous les soirs big
up à toi mon ami François civil parce
que c'est quoi le la chose qu'il a dit
de cette année dans TPMP que tu as
préféré François
il a dit Macron c'est pas bien ce que tu
fais quoi on a aussi trouvé les deux
fêtards les plus égocentriques de la
fête de la musique
agréable mais ça c'est incroyable bisous
pack ça y en a pas deux dans le monde
quand on est comme ça on est tombé sur
le sosie vocal de Nicolas pernico
avant que j'y joueur on a aussi
rencontré Isabelle Balkany qui est
visiblement se souvient plus de son
prénom alors comment vous appelez
Valérie Valérie c'est la fête de la
musique ce soir ah on va bien danser
hein c'est quelle heure là le début de
l'apéro ah bah ça y est on a déjà
commencé alors là je vois il est 19h03
ma montre on a commencé depuis que c'est
ça
non pas du tout mais la grosse surprise
de cette soirée c'était le frère de
Cyril Hanouna qui se promenait sur les
quais de Seine et Cyril Cyril
on est tombé sur une vanne que tu peux
comprendre que si tu as fait Maths Sup
de maspect alors c'est exponentiel et
cosinus qui vont à une soirée et là
exponentielle comme Blaise complètement
mort vraiment il va non pardon cosinus
complètement mort que signifie
complètement mort il boit à fond le
lendemain a mal de crâne pas possible
vraiment je demande mais punaises
pourquoi j'ai fait ça et là
exponentielle va avoir il dit mais
attends tu as déconné là pourquoi tu
fais ça et là cosinus répond bah ouais
mais désolé vieux je connais pas mes
limites
on est tombé sur un mec en cavale alors
les jeunes ça fait la fête de la musique
on a aussi croisé un mec très content de
nous voir
les gars peut-être voilà dédicace à
épiner oh vive voix normale mais qui
était pas fan de tout type de musique
bon ça dit quoi la fête de la musique
sympa pour l'instant mais je te mens pas
moi je suis pas trop rock'n'roll et
enfin on est tombé sur un mec qui aime
bien faire des blagues mais qu'il faut
pas trop faire chier quand même
qu'est-ce que les dents détestent les
dents d'été je ne sais pas une brique
rouge pourquoi ben quand tu la prends
dans les dents
ah
allez ça marche avec tout du coup plus
elles sont courtes puis elles sont
bonnes les blagues bah bien sûr on parle
pas d'autre chose pourquoi tu parlais de
quoi toi tu veux voir ma vie
j'adorais la blague moi je veux dire on
a vu Eliott et Thibault qui seront avec
nous l'année prochaine pour une
chronique donc voilà donc voilà vous
avez vu des nouveaux talons aussi qui
nous rejoignent la fête de la musique
c'est avant tout des mecs aussi qui
chantent des mecs qui dansent beaucoup
de talons vous avez notamment découvrir
la danse de l'araignée ça c'est un grand
moment regardez
pour la fête de la musique la France
était peuplée d'artistes et on est tombé
sur le mec le plus chill de la soirée
c'est quoi ton objectif de la soirée je
vais déambuler je vais voir si ça se
passe bien
attention on a aussi vu un slamer qui
hurle et qui aime aussi beaucoup babaix
comme tu es c'est la folie c'est la
folie inch'Allah tu es le cinquième
mondial de paddle tu es le premier
restons en forme on est aussi tombé sur
Hugo Clément mais qui était pas trop
dans le rythme ok Beach une éclipse tu
parles mal j'ai trop le seum 22h string
actrice on est tombé sur la fille de
Géraldine maillet qui est revenu tout
juste des Rasmus amanias
et aussi
on a retrouvé Isabelle Balkany elle est
toujours aussi qui adore celle-ci
[Musique]
bobo petit cul celui-ci
on est aussi tombé sur un danseur or
timing je vous ai mis danser peut-être
oui un petit peu on peut avoir une démo
une démo allez vas-y je vous suis
c'est quoi comme ça c'est une danse
africaine ah
et enfin le dernier extrait je vous
laisse regarder c'est déjà culte toi tu
vas nous faire quoi là l'araignée
c'est l'araignée c'est les gars non pas
encore pas encore encore
c'est l'araignée ça pas encore pas
encore
[Musique]
ça c'est l'araignée ça c'est l'araignée
c'est parti c'est l'araignée c'est
l'araignée c'est l'araignée c'est
maintenant donc Cyril tu fais la même
c'est magique
[Applaudissements]
ça arrive ça arrive t'es mal dit ça
arrive ça arrive ça arrive ça arrive et
j'ai adoré ça je voudrais voir si aussi
tiens j'ai oublié remercier Tarik Diego
Flavio et caleda mais ici mes amis qui
travaillent avec moi mes chéris ça c'est
les frérots aussi tu travailles avec moi
tous les jours
les amours il y avait aussi la fête de
la musique vous avez fait pour la fête
de la musique
on a voulu interviewer les gens et il y
avait toujours quelqu'un qui voulait
s'incruster c'est comme ça c'est la fête
de la musique c'est ce qu'on aime
regarder
vous savez ce qu'on adore dans les
magnéto c'est les mecs au second plan et
on commence avec un mec un point
d'agressif Cyril on t'aime de ma ville
tu es débile et je t'ai déjà vu
plusieurs fois dans ces mêmes déjà taper
la bise pour moi c'est super
divertissant continue avec un mec qui a
débarqué de Porte de Clichy pour pousser
la chansonnette vous connaissez
l'émission Touche pas à mon poste oui on
connaît tout à fait un mot pour
pour Cyril
alors Cyril s'apprécie beaucoup plein de
gros bisous je pense fort à toi tu as
une musique à chanter pour ça une
musique
il est où le bonheur il est où
il est où il est où le bonheur il est où
il est là et voilà il est là et enfin
pour le dernier admirer c'est pour ces
moments-là qu'on fait de la télé bon
comment allez-vous
tu as vu il a fait Cyril Hanouna merci à
lui s'il n'y avait pas que des Parisiens
on est aussi croisé beaucoup de
touristes d'étrangers et même eux bah
ils nous connaissait regardez connaissez
tous pas à mon poste c'est un truc de
ouf
alors vous le savez Paris est une
capitale multiculturelle et TPMP est
déjà connue aux quatre coins du monde tu
connais serrer la Nonna en Espagne
de tout le monde les voit bon bah
oui
quand c'est du cas vas-y
vous toucher à mon poste mais oui c'est
nous s'il y aurait reçu j'aurais fait
bien
quand je dis bah tu dis bah bah bah bah
bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah
bah bah bah bah bah bah I Love You Baba
bonjour
[Musique]
monsieur est en train de nous dire que
il consomme du vin le matin le midi et
le soir et que ça fait des années qu'il
apprécie ça et qu'il est complètement
rôti
[Applaudissements]
dans TPMP sachez-le les chéris il nous
reste un magnéto est-ce que c'était des
amours dans la fête de la musique qu'ils
avaient tous un mot pour moi et c'est
vrai que vous avez vu vous avez vu tout
le monde nous connaît c'est un truc de
fou mais c'est dingue parce que quand on
dit aux gens est-ce que tu peux dire
bonjour à chroniqueur et dis Cyril alors
je ne sais pas quoi faire peut-être que
je vais devenir mais pour l'instant je
ne suis pas chroniqueur